[Music]
yeah cool so thanks for joining this
talk is about how ad blockers are being
circumvented and basically what we're
doing to fight back
what are the challenges that we face on
a day to day basis and then what are we
trying to do to counter them a little
bit about me I'm product owner of
anti-circumvention at i/o which makes
sample plus previously I used to be head
of R&D at Bayer break with where I
basically tried to use technology for
making some solutions for people with
disabilities and before this I used to
work at opera amongst many things also
being p.m. of the extensions platform so
an entire micro industry has basically
popped up in the last few years
promising to bypass ad blockers so
basically they go to publishers and say
that even if your site isn't on the
users ad blockers whitelist
we can still somehow find a way to show
users ads they generally if you go to
their websites you'll say something like
recover blocked and impressions or
recover your block dance or gravia
recovery or unlock your ads so this is
coming up more as a problems back in
2016 there was this research paper which
analyzed all this it says we found that
at least six point seven percent of the
Alex at twelve 5k websites engage in
some form of anti ad blocking we call it
circa mention they call it Antion
blocking the arms race has already
entered the next level with one of three
popular browser extensions at work first
goes to your privacy badger can evade
half of the anti and blocking scripts in
our data set this was back in 2016 best
believe in 2019 this has scaled up even
more on both sides so you have more
people engaging in this kind of behavior
and there's also increased amount of
attention from ad blockers trying to
look at this particular problem as well
so what exactly is circa mention as I
said it's showing users ads but getting
around the ant Walker despite them not
being on the ant
or whitelist either implicitly or
explicitly now for obvious reasons this
is bad
yes but there are some non obvious
reasons why it's even worse so to talk
about this or to think about this let's
look at some types of opinions towards
ads and ad blockers so on one hand you
have some people who are just fine with
that either they don't know about a
blocker so they don't care or they as a
matter of a principal don't want to use
ant walkers I know a few people like
this on the other hand on the other
extreme you have people or what I call
the scorched earth mentality which is
like every bad is every ad is bad all
the time and block each and every one of
them don't support any online ads don't
care about publisher revenue and this is
a spectrum so there's something in
between where it's like okay most bands
are bad but not all of them are bad as
long as someone respects me and it's not
doing annoying stuff then I'm willing to
give them a chance and there's a lot of
movement within the industry to somehow
take these ad ad companies and try to
make sure that they follow some kind of
standards or some kind of rules for good
behavior whether it's the Coalition for
better ads or whether it's acceptable
ads or something so let's take a look at
just one of them called the acceptable
mask right here so no matter how big and
powerful you are no matter how much
money you have it doesn't matter at the
end if your ad has to be as part of the
except provides criteria these are the
things which are not allowed you know
and this is not an exhaustive list these
are just some of the things so animated
ads autoplay ads expanding as overlay
ads pop-ups pop-unders all these things
are not allowed no matter how much
influence you have now if you can
circumvent the ad blocker you don't have
to do any of these things right you can
do anything you want you can make your
ads as intrusive as possible as annoying
as possible and generally that's what
we've seen when it comes to circumvented
ads these are the worst of the worst on
the web and they make life miserable for
people online so this is why
circumvention is even worse than just
what may appear as obvious so before we
go let's talk a little bit about what
how ad blockers work on a very very high
level so you have a web
it has ads you have a browser extension
installed it's an ad blocker what it
does is it regularly updates from a
thing called a filter list which is a
community maintained list of filter
rules and if that site matches that
filter rule that piece of HTML or
whatever is blocked right and that's why
that's how you see a page without the
ads now generally the the biggest one
community maintain filter list is called
easy list but when it comes to circum
mention we wanted our own list in a VP
so a year ago we launched the
anti-circumvention filter list it's
specifically just to target certain
convention we wanted to give it a little
bit higher privileges as well so that we
can do a little bit more complex stuff
and it allows us to react extremely fast
to circle mentions so if if you detect
that someone is doing sir convention we
can push out the change and yeah it's
it's there instantly
browsers also a term users can generally
update this by default every 60 minutes
so it's regularly up to date so as as
we're moving fast to word circle mention
and pushing all these filters CV
providers or circle mention providers
they're forced to become faster to so
much so that there's a constant war
going on between the ad blocker and this
will be provider in terms of we we push
out a filter to block their ads they
change their content of the website we
once again push out a filter that
instance so this keeps on going on and
on and on and they constantly keep an
eye on our anti-sea with this repo
because it's open source anyone can take
a look so they're constantly keeping an
eye so one example of this was the
following we're one of our one of our
colleagues who pushes out a lot of
filters on a particular ad on a
particular website when he viewed the
source code he sound he found it
his name or his github username as one
of the classes so imagine he going to a
website he viewed the source code and
see your name over there and this was
kind of like I think from the from that
websites and kind of like a wink-wink
not just oh okay we know what you're
doing now and this is kind of like we
are sick knowledge in you so this is all
about filters but you know
it's a constant cat-and-mouse game
between ad blockers and circumvention
providers and somewhere in between this
game became more complex so it's not
just about you know the cat chasing the
mouse is there there's just stopped and
this started playing chess so things are
becoming a little bit more complex so
now we're going to talk about snippets
this so snippets are basically small
JavaScript functions designed to counter
one or more circumvention techniques
generally they're used when just writing
a normal filter isn't enough so you have
to do something more complex and then
significant amount of the filters in
aren't ante CV filter list is you know
using snippets snippets are also called
scriptlets in you block origin for
example and if you want to take a look
at the source code while everything is
open source so this is the URL so let's
take a look at a few case studies of
what we have to deal with in ad blockers
on a daily basis right so there was this
once CV provider would which didn't even
want you to take a look at what they're
doing right so what we did was kind of
like a jujitsu move using their own
energy against them and I'll explain
what I mean by this in the following way
so the CD provider what they used to do
was you know whenever you're trying to
go to the website and open up the
developer tools they used to detect this
and basically clean up all their code
remove the ads so that you cannot even
try to understand what's going on
you cannot even be bugged the code which
is when I when I found out I was like
what the hell is going on so we thought
long and hard about this and then we try
to use their own thing against them so
we developed the snippet which kind of
tricks the website into thinking that
the developer tools are already open
when in fact they're not so they did it
work for us so they just you know remove
the code themselves so yeah since then
they've caught on to this so they no
longer do this trick but it was quite
effective it quite funny for us as well
the other thing I want to talk about is
something called the abort on property
read or abort and property right
typically a lot of these sites or all of
these TV providers they
they want to access a particular
property or they want to write to a
particular property so what we do is we
kind of know which ones they're looking
for and we made a script to kind of
block block the script or award the
script as soon as we detected they're
trying to read a particular property or
write to a particular property this idea
was originally from you lock origin even
though our implementation AVP is
different than theirs but the overall
idea was from there and we give credit
over here as well as in the source code
and good on them for doing some
wonderful work the next thing that I
want to talk about is superfluous
element stuffing so there are a few
high-profile websites not just one but a
few which try to get around the fact
that you know you have posts and you
have to mention which pose are sponsored
so of course if if you just the normal
text you can just you know search for
that text it says sponsored and that's
the end of it but what they do is they
end up stuffing a bunch of elements they
break down the word sponsor into
different cat different parts and then
they do something like this so to make
things clear a little bit more this is
what they do so as you can see there are
some divs there's some spans some of
these elements are not going to be
visible so in the end it will say
sponsored visually but if you look into
the source code you'll find this right
so how do you deal with this it's just
you know something which is really
frustrating it bloats up the page it
doesn't help anyone so this is a this is
an approach that it's going to be there
soon in ABP we're still making a few
adjustments here and there but basically
what you do is you go through all of
these child elements and first what you
have to do is remove the invisible stuff
stuff that doesn't really the stuff
which is what we call decoy elements so
you check for invisible text you check
for a pasty zero or font size zero or
the Alpha Channel you check for
display:none or visibility:hidden or
collapse and basically as you go through
you ignore those you go through the ones
which are visible you
take the inner text and you concatenate
them and then if it says sponsored then
you got your you know your sponsored ad
so then you can do whatever you want
with it so this is the kind of stuff
that you know ad blockers always have to
deal with daily but this was still okay
there's another example where someone
said they're okay we have sponsored
person we have to make sure that this
has sponsored so instead of text now
they have something where it's just an
image and inside the image there's text
and it's really bad for accessibility
because it doesn't even have an alt
attribute so they don't care about
anything even then it would be okay to
detect this but what they also do is you
see this blank space that's also an
image that's the same PNG image as this
one the only difference is that this is
a transparent in PNG so you cannot see
this and the above one is obviously a
non transparent PNG so you can see that
so it looks a little bit like this so
it's a data URI and it's gonna be really
really difficult to kind of detect
what's gonna happen over here and to
make things even more complex they make
minor variations in in the way in which
they're serving images so in this case
for example this data you arrive for
this visible sponsored image can be any
of these three data URLs that you see
over there and the same thing for the
decoy labels it can be any of these
things so we had to look into the PNG
spec we had to do a lot of work
ultimately we found out some kind of
pattern which was only applicable to the
visible sponsored image and then what we
did was basically it's just a matter of
taking that image converting into a
base64 looking for that pattern and
matching it if it does then bingo we
finally have our PNG and label and then
we can do you know the blocking so yeah
there's a lot of stuff that we have to
do with you know circle mention on daily
basis over here so let's look at some
gaps and challenges that we have so when
it comes to this we
you know when it comes to circle mention
the effort is being fought on multiple
fronts it's not just one thing
so we have people who are working on
kind of reverse engineering what they're
doing you know people who are hardcore
JavaScript people then there's filter
list authors who are pushing out filters
you know on an hourly basis and then
there's many other things that I'll talk
about in the next few slides on the
other hand even though we have some
really smart people working for us to
kind of deal with this situation they
also have some really smart people on
their end and they're willing to go
through many creative lengths to get
around the ad blockers so it's it's a
daily challenge to keep up with what
they're trying to do and as I said this
this thing is being fought on the
multiple levels and not just a technical
level recently there's this landmark
Supreme Court case basically what some
publishers wanted to do was to kind of
argue that ad blocking itself is illegal
and they you know went to the lower
courts the higher courts and ultimately
to the Supreme Court an adverb plus was
at the vanguard of this and basically
argued that you know it should be legal
and the Supreme Court of Germany
actually said that yes it is actually
legal and you know it's totally okay to
use ad blockers and do ad blocking so
yeah when it comes to fighting you know
circumvention providers or publishers a
lot of times what you have is not just
people using technical approaches but
sometimes these kind of legal influences
as well gaps and challenges so apart
from this thing one more thing is the
fact that in Firefox you have an API
called the content scripts API which
means that you can have a reliable way
for the extension to for the extension
to run always before the site's code
which is actually good in forwarding a
lot of these circumvention things but in
chrome you don't have an equivalent API
so there's no reliable way to guarantee
that the extension scripts always runs
before the site scripts so that's that
but there's also the McCrone manifest v3
situation where there are some
significant architecture changes which
might be coming to Chrome extensions
which could impact or which will impact
actually a lot of ad blockers so you
know there are some things which are
welcome the background page architecture
might be replaced by a serviceworker
which is good there's a switch to a
promise based API instead of a callback
based API which is also good but there
are some major changes to the blocking
portion of web the quest API so this is
the this is the part of the extensions
API which allows you to block a network
request and this is something which is
going to be or at least is announced to
be changed
instead they'll have a decorator rule
based blocking instead which is then I
think Apple but it's from most of the
ant blockers if you read their opinion
it's still not in a good enough shape
right now and updating the rules from
the filter this might require a whole
new version release so right now if you
want to update the rules and easy list
all you have to do is just update the
easy list right it's it's there but if
you have to do this in this new v3 thing
then it might be the case that if you
have if you have to update your filter
list and you have to do a whole new
extension release where you send in your
extension to the Chrome Web Store once
again it gets moderated then it's get
gets released and if you have to do this
each and every day multiple times a day
is going to be impractical so we worked
together across ad blockers so ad block
plus
ad block ad guard gostrey and too easy
list authors montz and fine boy asthma
as well as malwarebytes we gave the
chrome team feedback on what are the
things that we would like to be there in
v3 what are the changes that we would
like it seems that the chrome team is
taking a look and and kind of evaluating
all of this but at the same time there's
oh there's a question mark over here on
what do they really want to do what what
is the what is the end goal when it
comes to ad blocking and you know when
it when it comes to v3 what exactly do
they want what what is the quality that
they want in
and blogging there's there's this
performance argument that okay you know
we want to make these changes because we
want to make things a little bit more
performant there's the security argument
as well but at the same time when it
comes to and blockers
if the effectiveness of and blockers is
harmed you know in circumvention will
rise once again and if that happens then
everyone will be just in a really really
bad situation so when it comes to this
I'll just end with this recently
released w3c tag ethical web principles
document which is something that every
browser makers should everyone should
read but especially all the browser
makers should read it says that people
should be able to render content as they
want users should be able to install
style sheets assistive browser
extensions blockers or unwanted content
or scripts or autoplay videos through
technologies such as browser extensions
people must continue to be able to
change web pages according to their
names so with this I would say I think
this is a pretty good way to end the
talk if you have any questions regarding
all of this I'm here after this talk and
tomorrow as well so I'll just say thank
you so much
[Music]